[Music]
well william hello dominic we are now
joined by the fantastic dante what's
going on dante
what our guest is here like straight
away at the very beginning that's how he
does the friendship onion that's how he
does it and you look fantastic i'm
lacking this style dante thank you
cheers cheers mate cheers every time i
see you dante you've you've always got
fantastic stale i appreciate i see you
guys at cons and i'm for everybody out
there listening and watching so the
hobbit dudes roll in right and they're
like the cool kids
is very
a little you know i i wave to you i say
hi but it's like a very you know
everyone at the con the green room where
the green room is where all the you know
the talent is kicking it in between
appearances and whatnot you know but the
hobbit's rolling they're like the cool
kids they're like they like the t-birds
i didn't know that i didn't know that
either oh for sure should we get jackets
like you should have jackets and t-bird
jackets for sure
would you is would you give your uh
style a name dante is there a particular
name california cool all right loving it
loving it kelly what's yours what my
style yeah
i think military punk well that's good
what's yours yeah
glasgow gallus
brilliant gallus always trying to get
the word in have we talked about dallas
on the show yeah i think that's the word
i've never heard of oh tell me what that
means
some definition
so in in scotland we have a lot of words
that people don't use in in other
countries we speak english
but we have well we have other words
right kind of
gallus is one of my favorites and gallus
means
when somebody is like slightly
dress maybe a little extravagant and
you'd see them and you say oh look at
dante he's looking a bit gallus today
right
dallas
that's what a g it was a g g-a-l-l-u-s
but also if you have a nice meal you
could say
that was gallus yeah
what would be bill's what would be
currently
some good examples of a gallus human
walking about gallus would be
um
messy
messy's pretty careless messy on the
football field soccer field laying on
there
what about machine gun kelly do you know
machine gun kelly yes he's a bit gals do
you know him yes of course
megan fox's fella yes he's cool he's
clearly very talented you look alice he
likes to let you know about it maybe a
little too girlish no two girls over
gallows
i like one of my favorite scottish words
which is another one that you don't hear
that often but billy's amazing wife is
an artist and she draws these things and
they're all over the house ela for a
swan he loves isn't that beautiful oh
look at that lovely wee ela
that's ila
scottish accent no i can't i can't
english accent no no no no no maybe no i
did audition for history boys and i had
to learn a british accent before that
i was hanging out with a a a scott scott
scar t-shirt yeah scottish yeah yeah i
caught one of the guys from game of
thrones very
very great guy and we were and i called
him a scotchman and he said dante yeah
donates
there
scott first scotch is a drink yeah yeah
and you can be a scot yeah but never a
scotchman it can be scotch or a scotch
yeah we don't know there were americans
we don't i said scotchman
and there was wrong like englishman
scottish englishman also there's a weird
thing that goes on in the united states
uh where they think there is such a
thing as a british accent there isn't a
british accent
britain is a collection of three
countries right
four is it four yeah so
scotland wales
england and northern ireland yeah are we
sure or is that not the united kingdom
britain to watch watch your show
i think i think britain is scotland
wales and england i think and i think
the united kingdom encompasses northern
ireland i always thought united kingdom
and britain were just a change
but anyway so obviously you can't have a
you can't have a combination of a
american canadian mexican accent so you
can have a scottish accent a welsh
accent an english accent we don't know
that as americans if you guys have your
accents here you understand that we
think you guys are all incredibly
intelligent and incredibly fashionable
and very desirable oh really you
definitely go up at least two three
points on the scale one through ten i
and i and i attribute it to you know
like anything you know a lot of times in
cultures it's just colonized cultures
like i'm filipino we you know we're
calling about spanish so someone spanish
was like oh they're spanish americans
we're we're like a scion of england like
we're kind of so
you guys are like our
we look up to you and we don't want to
admit it but when the english person
walks in the room we all listen uh you
shouldn't but i know we shouldn't and we
don't even know like as i've traveled
through through london and whatnot and
you you understand there's even within
england there's different accents of
like more
brutish kind of communities and more
posh we all think you guys are all posh
everyone doesn't matter right right and
i remember i was hanging out with
charlie hunter one time oh lovely child
and charlie is great and i was hanging
out with his dad when he was alive and
his brother and i was like you guys are
saying no mike these are they're
hooligans you don't understand like my
dad
well they'll beat you up you don't let
him into the party i'm like no we're
american like you guys will walk into a
party and we think you guys are all just
family members of the royal family upper
class everyone everyone
everyone's posh because i'm not posh i'm
like but you're you have a british
accent yeah well to us your posh to
finish the the scottish gallus thing as
as uh dom says my wife has this and
company called a gallus life where she
takes scottish words and phrases makes
art and clothes and i just noticed i'm
wearing one
can you clap your dog can uh
clap your dog what do you think that
means can you clap your dog can you clap
can you pet your dog yes can i oh can't
i you're a doug
so that's english it's a nice way to say
someone yeah scottish scottish
okay and it's uh if you meet someone
with a dog and you're like that dog
might bite me
if i ask it to pet can i pet can i pet
you
can i clap your dog can i clap your dog
that is perfect yeah i'm going to get
you one of those t-shirts i like to clap
your dog do you want it in black or
yellow black done
i want to see you wearing it though
because you cool you're cool how are you
next at the next convention we're going
to see you in toronto i'll see you in
toronto
next phanex toronto listen don't be a
stranger don't feel like you can't come
over to these cool kids it's a little
nervous
that that hobbit table is a little
nerve-wracking it's like going over the
cool kids trying to sit down and get you
a t-birds jacket you know have a little
carton of milk at the lunch you know the
lunchbox tonight
does anyone have this scene i think i
think who gets you in there though yeah
i think that alone gets i appreciate
that it's isn't it weird when you go to
conjure guys there's like there's pieces
of all of our i mean of course fans are
there in this piece of nostalgia but
we're act we're people too you guys it's
pieces of our nostalgia sitting at
tables all around yeah and it's like the
hobbit guys there's like the karate kid
cobra hi guys there's like you just see
all these star trek yeah there's a hulk
and he's like i want to go say hi i'm
fonzie i meant fun
you're like i just got to say hello to
you yeah we can have those moments too i
had it at the last convention corey
feldman was there oh corey growing up
i mean he's a legend i'd seen him from a
distance before but didn't get a chance
to see him we chatted and uh it was a
lovely conversation and when he left he
said see you later billy
crazy
i grew up with corey and i had not seen
him in a bunch of years i did a project
when we were teenagers lovely and we ran
to each other in the bathroom and we had
a 30-minute conversation
in the bathroom
i couldn't i was trying to get out but
cory you know it's like you're in the
middle of the conversation that's where
we met he was going heavy in it and i
was like i guess i'm going to stand here
while everyone else goes to bathroom
that's where we met today right i was
peeing and you walked past your head and
i was like oh i can't wave right now the
doctor said i'm not supposed to hold any
uh everything i said how are you doing
chilling yeah just chilling
i should have i said chilling as you
walked through i went and pissed that
you missed that day
i should do a quick league of legends
update well first off oh back up we
haven't really introduced on to anyone i
know
you know we haven't even we're just
hanging out we're just hanging out do
you mind if i do a very small please
four lane
lines is great just an embarrassment for
you
a blurb dante bosco
or dante r pasco what's the alpha rufio
no
is a filipino-american film television
and voice actor is probably best known
for his role as rufio the leader of the
lost boys and steven spielberg's hook
and for as many voice acting roles most
notably as prince zuko from
nickelodeon's avatar the last airbender
jake long from disney channel's american
dragon jake long and spin kick from
carmen san diego
how's that now that's a perfect link
just a just a little just a touch of
your life just an absolute yeah yeah
just like they give you like someone
reads a whole page and a half of your
wikipedia and then you've got to walk
out like
and it's back to things like you did at
drama school yes and you're like no
that's too much yeah we need to we need
to update it
now a word from our sponsor better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life that's how our brains work
so why don't we treat them that way how
we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and care into keeping them
healthy dom everything that happens in
your life happens in your mind oh true
think about that for a second so you've
got to keep your mind healthy and a big
part of that is talking about your
experiences talking about what you're
going through and if you don't have
someone to talk to i think better help
is a great idea
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours our
listeners get 10 off the first month at
betterhelp.com
onion that's better h e l p dot com
slash
when running a business your employees
can create all kinds of interesting
situations like getting complaints
because someone on the team always
smells awful like my friend here to my
right hello well you better talk to
bambi with bambi get access to your own
dedicated hr manager starting at just 99
per month they're available by phone
email and real-time chat so on-boarding
and terminations run smoothly team
members reach peak performance and your
business stays compliant with changing
hr regulations and with bambi's hr
autopilot you'll automate important hr
practices like setting policies training
and feedback and let me tell you about
bambi's dedicated hr managers bills they
are u.s based people dedicated to your
business lovely for your business out
there giving you access to hr expertise
and personal touch that you need hr
managers can easily cost 80 grand a year
but bambi started 99 a month that's a
saving schedule your free conversation
today to see just how much bambi can
take off your plate bambi matches you
with your very own dedicated hr manager
that you can easily reach by phone chat
or email bambi's dedicated hr managers
will know your business and your
specific concerns implement the most
important hr practices for small
businesses on autopilot visit bambi.com
right now spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash onion bambi.com
we were talking just before the show
started about the fact that
israel added sanya who is the light
heavyweight champion at ufc and probably
one of the more exciting ufc fighters in
the last
five or ten years or so is a huge
uh airbender fan uh and he is definitely
gallus yeah he's definitely oh yeah he
calls himself the style bender oh no i
do know you're talking about the style
bender that's him because he mixes
styles he's a beast i saw one fight with
him and he was too
you easy hit him up on instagram and say
hey i do this voice and he'd probably be
like oh what's up that's his favorite tv
show i would love to hit him up and it's
crazy especially the fighters especially
that there's one of the wwe wrestlers
um xavier woods he came out as roofio
and he came with the trihawks and
everything and the
everyone was like chanting rufio and of
course my twitter and stuff blew up
people said
and so he i reached out to him just like
yeah that was you know bang rang and
then he sent me tickets to his next show
in staples center we went
and saw him perform live that was crazy
can i can i do uh an email that came in
from one of the listeners don because
it would be good at this time
it's from berto08
and he says uh dom
so it's to you dumb yeah
you like avatar the last airbender i do
what kind of bender would you be and why
and what about you billy if you haven't
seen it please make him watch it as you
know it will change his life thank you
guys i love the podcast he hasn't seen
it and he didn't know dante was going to
be honest i think a little research
really a little research i've been i've
been trying i've been trying to get
billy to watch a ton of things over the
years and billy has done with me as well
but um you just don't have the time do
you bills i don't have the time i know
there's just too many things to watch
there's a lot he's bulking right now i
don't know if you know dante but he's
been backing over
i was enjoying eating right we all have
drink oven i just eaten a lot and i
thought
while i'm eating
why don't i just lift heavy things
and then maybe i'll feel better about
eating and getting heavier and it works
it works now i get up in the morning
i've gone to scale and i'm like yes i've
gained five pounds we know muscle weighs
more than fat exactly so now like now
the weight now that the scaled means
nothing you know my head spaces has
changed and now i just want to get huge
are you going for it i'm gonna i'm
really going for it but this is a bulk
up and there's the cut i'm not doing the
camera he's not cutting he's getting
like world's strongest man big
yeah so not cutting anyway no cuts no
definition just the world's strongest
man events carrying the big heavy ball
and yeah that's crazy stuff
yeah is there anyone in particular that
you could like
talk about in terms of body size that
would be your goal that people would
know out there like we know jeff capes
but i don't think a lot of people know
jesus
daddy and then that guy eddie
the first guy that he lifted the ton
didn't he eddie hall yeah eddie hall but
i want to see you ready like marvel
ready no
i'm not going no cut no we're just going
to cut no
maybe more like justice the strength
yeah the thing would that be right do
you know the thing yeah fantastic four
do you know once we were talking about
conventions and stuff and there was
another time in my life a while back
when i was lifting heavy weights
and i wasn't putting on muscle
and i was i saw ringo oh yeah so i went
over to him the hulk and i says look i'm
lifting heavy weights here lou
and why am i not putting on muscle and
he says you're not eating enough
so now i've started eating before i've
even started lifting put the put that
those calories to work my trainer told
me years ago 70
diet yeah i said if if you have an
impeccable diet and you don't really go
to the gym you will sooner or later look
fantastic if you go to the gym and your
diet is terrible you look awful can i
ask you about the toilet carry on
any changes in your toilet um going
experiences other than i would think
probably weight would be the only you
would say bigger girthier i would say
sorry dante no it's okay
singularly singularly
singularly the jobby looks the same it's
another scottish word
which means a poo okay ajabi and majobi
looks the same it's not good it's not
girth here but i would think it's
probably get more mass
is could you pick it up the next time i
could probably pick i don't know how far
i could throw it i wouldn't bring it
into this you think it's denser it's
definitely denser you know like things
can be the same size but heavier dense
they say a black hole maybe is only the
size of a a tennis ball right but it
weighs as much as a galaxy right that's
crazy well that's what my job is like
just
like a tablespoon of like uranus is like
the planet uranus oh well we were
talking about his age
yeah he's like you know 100 pounds or
something wow and just to conclude on
that bills stench any change in stench
no smell at all brilliant and one flush
gone gone should we make one carry on i
love your guys a scientific acumen i'm
on the situations i was listening to
your pockets so you guys were talking
about just a quick side note the
fahrenheit celsius thing oh yeah do you
know any insights the one inside i will
tell you i'm american so i grew up with
fahrenheit and i'm like you know i think
who was i don't know what you couldn't
believe it was incorrect i was correct
yes okay so when i go to
asia or europe they're all on celsius i
mean americans are ridiculous we're
we're in the inches and
we should probably all be one thing but
i get confused too so zero to 100
celsius is freezing and and and boiling
water which makes sense
however what i found out which makes
more sense now is i said well then why
who created how they create fahrenheit
and someone told me oh when they created
fahrenheit they thought a hundred
degrees was the body temperature of the
human
later on they found out we're 98 degrees
or it varies but so fahrenheit is based
on the human body so at 100 degrees is
what the body our bodies are you know
roughly 100 degrees yeah yeah so that's
the difference of it and that's in
fahrenheit that's fahrenheit that's the
one piece of information i was like
that's the one thing that makes sense
okay that's helpful so when it's super
hot outside like today yeah and it's
like 90. yeah our body is like 10
degrees lower than our body our body's
that hard
we run very hard yeah you touch a human
yeah they're hot
aren't they yeah well you sleep next to
your wife right do you not ever just
like stick out before you go oh yeah but
it doesn't feel like outside just now
what's 10 degrees 10 degrees lighter is
a different it's a big difference yeah
they're hot
and also this is what gets confusing
zero degrees celsius is also zero
degrees fahrenheit no no no no no sure
no it's a negative for negative zero
negative 40 degrees
celsius is negative 40 degrees
fahrenheit why don't you get to negative
40 they they match each other
that's what it is and what's amazing at
that point is you could take a warm
bucket of water at that point
outside
and throw it and it's going to become
snow instantly oh i love that you throw
in the air and become snow well
minus four is something like that and
sometimes it becomes minus four it
doesn't like in canada yeah it does yeah
on videos
it comes here yeah it comes out our
friend steph bills who makes us who's
made those two pictures on the back of
the wall they're done yeah yeah and
makes a lot of artwork for us told me
today
that celsius and centigrade is
is actors talking about science yeah i
love science actors talking about
science in particular i like it too
that's the best thing that's one of the
best science
students in the world yeah i like it too
why do we find it so interesting because
we didn't study it hard enough in school
and we just thought it was cool it could
be that we studied other things creative
things also you'll find what's in stream
uh for me at least is i find that the
people that i'm closest to in my life
i like to know about their uh bowel
habits so i'm i asked billy quite a lot
about it that's quite a personal
question my brother
my good friends when i see them it's
been a while so everything right
everything normal anything going on i
would not do that with someone that i
didn't know but i do often quite ask you
don't i why is that i don't know i think
it's like an intimacy thing right oh
yeah into me i see
yeah
my brother one time we were shooting a
movie together dionysio and he was
feeling bad his stomach and he had this
ulcer going on he almost didn't couldn't
shoot but we had his indie film so we
like we have to shoot like there's no
not doing it and he said you can't smoke
you can't eat bad foot all stuff of
course two weeks in the shooting
he's up at night smoking cigarettes he's
eating the taco bell that came in the
you know second meal
and he wakes up one morning knocks my
door and he's i'm knocking on his door
because we're looking for him he's like
it's not good i'm like it's not good
he's like looking really
just pale he goes i i i pooped and it's
it's dark i go
how dark and he looked at me goes you
know night
i said you know night you know night
that is dark it was dark
er but to this day we'll we'll look at
him go hey you know night you know night
how dark is it you know night oh
oh scary that's scary that is scary poop
can sometimes be a little bit scary
um well there's another question here
bills should we do these later or should
we do them now carry on all right well
there's a question here
um
dante might join us
there was a bender
i
question
okay well if i could be a
i've been called a bender you got fire
water air
but if this says a new one or a new one
if you have a new one going no it
doesn't seen you oh it's just what kind
would you be so fire
yeah there's the earth kingdom the air
nomads the fire nation
and the water the water tribe all right
well i've had the last one can he he can
do all of them is that right that's the
avatar yeah he's the avatar or she goes
the generation
rebirth like the buddha right nice i
would be air out of all of those because
sometimes you're not around water and
then you've negated your powers and
sometimes you're not around i see energy
being air plus air is kind of
you know tricksters kind of like light
and kind of very
you know they you know move air it's
just
i like the air well okay what about you
well your character's a firebender fire
nation all the time
now do you need fire to be there like if
there's no fire you can't do anything um
you can you create we create fire you
can create yes yes by the rubbing of
your thumbs just we we come from within
it comes from within
or you can just get it like that yeah
well that's quite good you like that
show the water benders need to be around
i'll have you yeah
i think you're fire um
hold on
nothing a big water
sea float is a water you need water
around if you're gonna be a water bender
you need water around you're not
summoning water from anything but i
can't take water out the air i haven't
maybe you're a high level
water speaking
that's like that's part water better
part airbender if you can do that can i
freeze the water and create yes you can
do that you can freeze water yeah i'm
having that then okay that'd be great
i'm going surfing tomorrow so i'll see
your surfers i've got water in my head
right now you'll have it in your ears
i can have a quick question to you guys
because when i was in england
they call our show you know it's avatar
the last airbender here and around the
world but in england they were calling
it the adventures of aang
because they said the word bender
is maybe known as like
gay or something like that it has a
negative connotation it's like a slur is
it a slur yeah it's a shame so do you
guys but
no whatever your bender airbender
waterbender in america i think is
commandeered in in a way that you know
we're okay with but yeah certainly in
england there's an unfortunate word it's
an unfortunate word in england
okay yeah so they changed the names
they're like you're the one the stars of
the adventures of aang i'm like huh
yeah
yeah i guess i am
i was in i was in where was i i was in
ecuador once season two of doing this
nature show and these italian tourists
came over to me i didn't speak italian
obviously but someone translated
and they said
you are the magician of animals and i
was like what what and they went you're
the magician of animals and i was like
what does that mean and then they had it
further translated and they said in
italy
your show which is called wild things is
called the magician of animals i was
like that's brilliant that's just right
i am that's a longer tattoo to have but
yes yeah that is me i like that i like
when they change the names i like it too
i like it too
if you haven't heard already it's smooth
sack summer oh yes smooth sack tom you
want to keep your balls cool this summer
and i'll tell you who's going to help
with that man escaped the leader in
below the belt grooming they're making
sure that you have a ball this summer
and uh keeping everything fresh so dive
head first into smooth sax summer by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with our code onion
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer features a
cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 has a 7 000 rpm motor and
a new multi-function on off switch that
can engage a travel lock so it doesn't
you know wake up while it's in your
luggage and gives you the ability to
turn the 4000k
led spotlight on and off when needed for
a more precise shave fantastic dom and
manscaped even throw in two free gifts
with their performance package 4.0
they'll give you boxers which are very
comfortable i like them very much and
the shed travel bag that will bring
comfort to another level get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code onion
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code onion at
manscape.com
it's smooth sex summer boys get on board
i'm getting left behind i don't know if
you remember but when i was doing like
indie movies and things i used to always
try and put happy days i always tried to
get my character to say happy days at
some point it's great
and uh
and one film that i did which is called
uh on a clear day
in in britain when it went to france
they called it happy days
and i loved
that's great it always do it just as i
was walking out or somewhere or
something like ah happy days you know
something
and they called the movie that that's
brilliant i loved it
well dante yes
what we tend to do on these shows with
our guests is we take it right back all
the way back because what we hope to do
let's go is maybe inspire people who are
watching or listening to the show and
hearing about the journey of your life
to have done the things that you've done
as an actor so right as a young boy or a
young man
what happened for you to find yourself
being a professional actor well i
started my whole career i tell people on
you know my whole career in the
entertainment industry i started the
ground level of the entertainment
industry and people like what is that
you know what is that it's like an extra
or is it like a like no it's for me it
was the actual ground me and my brothers
were street performers
in the streets of san francisco we were
break dancers we were a group called the
street freaks and we danced in the
streets had out changed boom box carport
box out there in the 80s like in the
pioneering days of hip-hop right yeah
and we became a very popular
breakdancing group in the bay area san
francisco and we won all these
breakdancing contests we got
scholarships at the san francisco ballet
company and we started this kind of path
of
you know being an artist that led us to
la i by the time we got to la we already
danced we were dancing for the san
francisco 49ers and the oakland a's just
the two of you not just four of his four
brothers and my sisters five of us and
so that led us to l.a but then we came
to la and that was 10. a lot of all that
stuff happened before i was 10. oh wow
yeah and then when i was 10 i got to
ellen we started got jumped into acting
class and started really learning acting
i didn't do hook tiles 15 so by the time
i did hook i was like a a veteran a
young jedi
young vet you know but at what point
during that journey as a you know
breakdancer performer street dancer did
you then think oh actually i'm okay at
this but i prefer acting it just happens
immediately because as soon as you get
to la
you realize this is a
this is a movie town this is a movie in
television it's like and i continue to
we dance for michael jackson we
continued to dance for for several years
but
you know i just one of those things like
the first thing auditioned for as an
actor i booked and then kind of kept
rolling with it and ultimately did a
bunch of films and got discovered by
spielberg but we were heavily in acting
schools i studied acting for 20 years
and so
me and my brothers and my sister we
we studied acting forever like very
serious hook i was a very serious young
actor you know we were i mean i'm
working with spielberg which is
a god and then of course justin hoffman
who i've studied all his films i'd go on
the set every day reading his
biographies being like young man hey
dustin when when you do this in cramer
vs kramer like how didn't this seem like
when you were doing
you know ratzel rizzo like how like i
was literally showing showing up on my
days off to watch hoffman act yeah yeah
and robin williams improv and
and sit by spielberg so i was like super
serious young actor but uh wait so what
era michael jackson were you dancing for
him like the bad air there's a movie
there's a video it's the moonwalker yeah
so they did a video of like the kids in
bad like the the bad video but with kids
and so we me and my brother were in oh
yeah there's like a minnie mouse
yeah minnie michael jackson so my
brother was there and i was
understanding my brother that you know
we were all part of that dance crew
right doing that but we were dancers for
a long time still dancer you know what's
a dancer always a dancer billy's are
dancing
almost every day i love dancing i love
dancing too it's yeah it's one of my
favorite things i dance every day have
you this is one thing you're talking
about we we me and my brothers and my
friends we always kind of dare each
other
when we're doing films and projects like
i dare you to like do something like
dancing dance in the movie yeah yeah
just somewhere in that movie i just dare
you to do it like there's inside tricks
when we're watching what they do we go
to premiere or screening of it and we
laugh because we're like oh he did it
i did i did a
a sitcom called empty a british sitcom
for bbc
and the writers
would write a dance for me every week
really yeah so it might be uh
oh i'm trying to remember some of the
names um
kind of old dance stars from the 20s 30s
40s and then i would spend the week
watching really old foodies to try and
get their moves like something
crazy yeah and they they wrote it in
every week and i loved it that was my
favorite thing in that i i actually
ended up doing a dance film when antonio
banderas called uh take the lead so it
was very cool later
to finally like do a dance movie it felt
like a full circle thing you know and
did you do it you said you got a
scholarship for the san francisco
ballet company yeah so did you do yeah
we all me and our brothers all studied
ballet there for uh a year or so we did
the nutcracker we were oh we were there
in tights learning ballet it's really
very very billy elliot when we watched i
watched i remember watching billy
elliott my brothers when was in theaters
and we were like
moved to tears because it was really it
was our story like blue-collar kids that
somehow became artists i love that film
yeah
breaks my heart until 10.
christmas yeah christmas and san
francisco in the whole wow lovely
memories you must have with that
i mean how's your point is it still good
it's all right now that's i'm all right
i mean my you know my turnout my turnout
my turnout look at my feet look at those
feet i'll look at you you're good
look at those beautiful feet you got
some right you do got a heavy point
that's like a nice
are you a dancer at all dumb i broke
both my feet i used to be
i'm quite ashamed of my feet now
no i did i broke my door and what i
brought my left foot surfing i broke my
right foot on her on a motorbike in a
motorbike accident but like broke my
right foot in four places
i ride motorcycles can't do anything
with my fate geez i'm so sorry this week
you still ride are you done right now no
no this was this is what happened when
when i came off that bike and i was like
recovering i said
if you get on a bike again then you've
absolutely blown it because there's the
lesson the lesson is don't get on a bike
right right so no then going back but
you know i used to kick the ball around
a lot not kick the ball around since my
broken feet but um
yeah i remember think when i'm sitting
around the pool when i was younger i
remember thinking oh quite fun feat them
quite fun hobbit feet and now they're
all mangled they look like they've been
in there you always keep them covered
now don't you know
are you nervous about your feet now you
little
well
but what about your turn now you were
about to see your is your turn out not
great my what your turn my turn is great
my turn is still oh is it good but you
need that for bali you need that for
battle i love i still love ballet i
still go watch the dance i love dancers
i love dancing still yeah it's one of
the greatest uh
it's like musicians
i think i love us as actors because
we're communicating but when you
communicate without
language
that's like
the ultimate communication yeah you know
and even when we're acting even though
we're saying lines we're actually the
actors are communicating
without the lines yeah and that's that's
when you're doing good stuff yeah and so
that's what i really love about dancing
because once you kind of got that
connection you're you're you'd have i
mean the days of going out to clubs and
just getting lost on dancefloor you're
having all these incredible community
conversations on the dance floor with
people i used to love that and uh that's
the best well we recently and i recently
did quite i would say quite a profound
uh dance of cotton eye joe at a festival
cotton eye joe yeah
don't know dallas florida that now i
think dallas right dallas because you
know it's kind of makes sense
and the girl
on stage just said do you want to try
cotton ijo and we said yeah what are the
moves and she showed us and billy and i
had it down cold and i think sean lunch
is slightly i think they're a little uh
intimidated by our gift i think so um
everybody was on stage all the guys four
of us did it wow
but i think the four of us actually
doing it correct lasted a couple of
seconds and then just a moment
yeah so then right so now you're you're
doing hook
you're in l.a
doing acting classes yes doing all of
that now was it easy to get hooked
yeah what's the audition process for
that you know had they seen you that's
the weirdest thing ever because i was
like i auditioned one time oh really wow
that's the thing isn't it with those
biggest
one time for the casting they put on
tape and then
i'm a kid you know well rufio had such a
distinctive look do you know i mean not
that yeah but he wasn't i don't know
what he want they wanted at first
because i went and they like stephen
wants to meet you and then you go to
back a lot of a universal to amblin at
the time which is still there and
you know for all the kids in l.a
especially during that times like steven
spiel the legend with steven spielberg
has a full video arcade in the office
you hear other kid actors talking about
that so i get to the office about a
dozen of us kids there for callbacks or
different things
and we walk the door and there's a full
arcade this is 1990 right so there's
like there's no ps2 there's no xbox we
and maybe nintendo didn't it's just
atari i don't think nintendo really came
out strong
but when you walk in his office there's
like a full-on arcade like at the mall
like the cabin it's everything and
they're like go play and we're playing
whatever galaga dig dug whatever all
these games right
and we're playing for like half an hour
so and you forget that your hair burnt
audition yeah yeah that's great probably
right
loose the guy the woman cast me on she's
like stephen we'll see you now and i'm
like oh wait a minute oh no i'm dick
duggan high school
and then uh i get back there and me and
steven
he starts talking to me and he talked
about i did another film called perfect
weapon he was like what's that movie
like and i was like i played this street
urchin kid he's like kind of street kid
he's like you know like rats or rizzo
and he got and steve was like like do
you say rats original i'm like yeah like
rats are you like dustin i like wrestle
resolutions
what then we start talking about
midnight cowboy i don't like this i'm
like this 14 year old 15 year old kid
and he's like we're talking we're
talking about midnight cowboy and we're
talking about dustin and then
we're having like a 30 minute
conversation about movies and stuff
and then um i literally was in the
middle of the of the conversations hey
do you want me to read the
the audition piece and he's like oh no
you don't have to read it
i said what he goes no i just wanted to
meet you
and i'm like
okay i walk out my you know my mom's
there with me she's like driving the car
out and she's like how'd it go i'm like
i don't think i got it mom yeah i didn't
she was like what she i didn't read it
she was like what i was like i didn't
i didn't read the audition he's with the
i said we just talked we talked
and i was like well i whatever i didn't
you know bummer i didn't read it then
two days later they offered me the part
just straight like that yeah
people you know the guys who can really
do it they know yeah you know like
spielberg he knows i'm looking at you
yeah he's picking up on your
intelligence right and your vibe
yeah i mean i guess i i asked him one
time when i was on the set in the middle
of the show like how did why did you
cast me like i didn't even read the
thing he's like i saw your tape yeah i
met you and he goes we we auditioned
thousands of kids across the country and
you're the only kid that scared me oh
that's cool a little edgy yeah it's a
little edgy yeah
so did you know at the time that dustin
huffman was going to be in it
you did oh yeah
i mean
dustin's like for me
dustin's on that pantheon you know the
mount rushmore the seventh actor
i mean pacino de niro hoffman yeah yeah
redford radford nicholson yeah you know
with the character actor rebecca is
awesome
was like the
he was like he's the leading man these
are the character actors that became
leading men for sure and changed the
landscape of what hollywood will forever
look like
and so i mean literally i'm on my days
off watching hoffman yeah
and just being this kid it was crazy
dude i love that thing that hoffman
doesn't hook with his mouth he does this
mustache thing yeah you know like little
twitchy thing when he's feeling
uncomfortable or like if something's
going on that he that he needs to
address he'll be like
so good and i love how vain he is in
that film you know like his hair has to
be yes yes
he's a he's he's
he's a god i mean they're guys like
certain like as a young actor you're
walking around like you guys know you
have been these amazing actors when
you're in the presence of greatness it's
like it's great that you're wrong with
them you want to learn but you also want
to see like how
they do it yeah yeah you do and what was
hoffman's process when you watched him i
mean his intensity and his detail
and just his method right so he
is captain hook like he's kept from date
from the
from the beginning of the day the end
he's like he's captain hook right okay
even when he's talking to me he's
talking about him
yeah he's kind of talking to me as
captain hook he did this thing
he did this thing to me so he's like
i was 15 right and it just so happened
that i was i don't know i was getting
into kind of conversation i don't know
now we're talking to people but i lost
my virginity during the the shooting of
hook
but no one knew i'm 15. you know this is
right
but i'm showing up on set some of these
days i'm not working a show up on set
and i'm like i guess i'm dressed up a
little i'm a little brighter and
dustin's doing captain hook he's doing
the scene and he's doing this this and
he sees me next to the camera and he
goes uh rufio
you know
you're looking bright today he's like a
roof are you getting some rufio
and i must have flushed red and he's
like looking at me and he's like just
remember it's not the size
of the wand it's the magic it makes
i just about lovely
on set
i love it
i mean he did that all in captain hook
yeah yeah in front of the whole it was
crazy and you're just sitting there like
oh you said he was method
and attention to detail so did that show
up as a lot of questions to steven
spielberg was he constantly asking stuff
i mean i was a kid so i wasn't in
involved in their conversations with
them i just
saw how he and this again i'm not as
method as that he heals that holds the
character
like strong like through the whole thing
and consequently you got another just as
great actor in a different way robin
williams on set dude
this whole different thing and improving
and
kind of like engaging with everybody in
the set in a way that he knew everyone
and
kind of kept the morale of the set going
you know it's a big movie like like the
hogwart
it's fun it's great but it's also a
14-hour day 16 hour days yeah you know
hundreds of people on the set and it's
like
to get that machine moving you need that
person at the top that's like let get on
my back let's go yeah and and robin was
really that guy and taught me so much on
just
that you know that energy and that kind
of
it was a different thing you saw these
two guys working in different ways but
working together and that that stuff is
definitely on screen like when you guys
are
doing the eating stuff and all that you
can just tell that everybody is up in a
sort of whoa
robin williams he's a god i mean i was a
fan of him since morgan mindy oh yeah i
mean his movies i really love the world
according to garp and the moscow on the
hudson and and then i really really
loved deadpool society like that poet
society was like as a kid we we we
created our own dead poet society yeah
and i was telling dust robin about that
and we would so robin's like this on the
set you know his very big energy for the
step but then we're in the makeup room
in the morning
we're just talking about poetry
he's like did you check out this poem oh
i'm like i was reading buckowski check
out butkowski oh check out uh this other
throw apartment like and we would just
talk about poems and poetry
so i got to see different aspects of him
and shared
that that part of it because i mean the
poet society i'm a poet too so i write
poetry i started a poetry venue in my
living room some 25 years ago right and
so this poetry venue
it became i mean it went from my living
room to a sandwich shop to a theater to
theater became
the biggest poetry venue opened mic
venue in the country became the the
became what you know the inspiration
became deaf poetry german hbo which then
went to broadway got a tony and a lot of
that's attributed to
you know especially those early days of
writing poetry to robin williams being
so supportive of me being a poet wow
yeah they always can just change your
life right yeah little moments like that
and we were lucky enough to meet him
here and there
he was a fan of rings so we met him a
few times on the red carpet we played
charades with him really one night and
then in new york yeah theater in new
york i think it was edna ed norton i
think he was raising money for a theater
in new york yeah and they had and you
know robin williams my rudolph
they were all super duper talented at
the top of that list in terms of
notoriety how scared you got you guys
like
whatever we were kids we were just
having fun but i remember thinking even
at the time i remember thinking wow i'm
watching robin williams improvise and
neville knows that you're impressed
right but improvising at a super fast
right high level so that's crazy he was
extraordinary he's extraordinary and
once he once he heard me he did a
scottish accent the whole night after
that yeah
yeah he's so yeah he's doing that he
sort of misses out fire i don't know i
mean imagine acting with him that people
like did you improvise i'm like no
no i did not improv with him just let
him go it's like you have you said yeah
no you have three choices you can either
improv he's marlon brando of improv yeah
all right he to go there you should be
on a level you should be a black belt
you either try to do that you probably
get bulldozed yeah or you know you can
just
crumple right
and get bulldozed yeah well my my my
strategy was like i'm gonna let them go
yeah yeah and then i'm gonna say my next
line right but i think that was great
though that's all you could do
but that was your character yeah yeah
yeah i mean that's great that it worked
out you know yeah i always thought
because obviously you know the roles
that he's played over the years
generally have a lot of kind of charisma
and high energy but i think one of my
favorite robin williams performances is
in awakening series
yeah which is a very very sad film and i
remember thinking as i got older is he
cracking jokes and having fun
or is that one of those moments i don't
know with de niro
can you just quiet down over there robin
what a man
brilliant um
okay so hook correct and then
obviously at this point in your life
you've been directing so at what point
after hook did you then start thinking
i'm going to expand into that like the
last 10 years i've been acting you know
i'm one of those guys like jeremy and
actor just kind of keep going but i'm
also filipino so i got to do some of the
i did the first filipino film ever made
in hollywood called the debut and i've
been a part of the whole asian american
scene that's been rising over the years
and being a part of that which
ultimately kind of like bursted during
crazy rich asians and now right a lot of
other things are going i'm working how
crazy today
they're pretty they're they're pretty
cool
and all those cats chris
yeah so they're they're all homies and
it's really you know collectively
we're just we've been a small community
within hollywood and everyone's been
working we're trying to get it to a
place where our stories matter and and
we can get our stories funded yeah it
really is right yeah and so it's been
it's been a process what generation was
your family uh in california like yeah
i'm i'm i'm kind of like
1.2 my or 2.1 i guess because my
grandmother my grandparents were world
war ii vets on both sides and they came
over after world war ii and then
my dad and my mom my dad was born in the
philippines but he was born in a bait
he's born an american in the philippines
and camera so they they don't even speak
the language anymore they like or ever
i'm not sure if they ever did and so
we're their kids right so we're like
kind of two second generation or 1.5 or
something like that right there's a
great martial art from the philippines
yes uh calling cali cali sticks yeah
yeah do any kelly i got i mean i got you
know heaven heaven heaven seven have you
got your heaven sex
i'm confused cali was my probably my
favorite martial art when i used to do a
lot of martial arts yeah i loved it
because it was stick fighting so it was
super fast but you could get rid of the
sticks and do it empty-handed or with
knives brilliant or with knives yeah
it's it's a it's an amazing master
two-handed two-handed with sticks with
sticks like little sticks so you used to
kind of go to class with your sticks
look at that he's no he knows what's
going on bill because you know one of my
kind of like life goals is to come at
you with two
two sticks or two knives so could we do
that in your garden next week absolutely
and i have been training my whole life
to stop you doing exactly this is going
to be a clash of the titans can we can
we put on tick-tock yeah that's right
now i'm not on tick-tock billy's
obsessed he's obsessed
yeah i think it is a modern sort of
artistic
you know what i mean people are learning
these dances they're doing really fun
movies i really like it's a fascinating
medium and i
i kind of get addicted i love to my tick
tock was great although my tech talk
just got hacked like a week ago oh did
they do nasty stuff no they someone took
it cause they tic toc gave me my name at
dante yeah which i guess is a very
valuable thing we have one name
and then it's been scaling super hard
for the last year or so during covid and
then they just someone just actually a
brit they said someone in london took
your name subhuman scum and what are
they doing over there what's happening
and then what happens so on tick tock
they're they're freezing everything and
trying to get it back so you'll get it
back i will be back at dante on tick
tock that's where you're going to get
your good stuff william do you dance oh
no sorry no i'm sorry i was going to say
could you share with dante the video
that got you on to tick-tock my very
very favorite one the wolfy thing yeah
right now well you could definitely uh
share it there or describe it we could
put the link in the show but yeah what
is it what is it it's a wonderful i
might have seen it i'm sure you have
it's uh it's a hound dog
who's sitting on a bed and he's doing
his hound dog thing
and
his owner saying what is it what's wrong
oh
and then he he farts
like that the hound dog does and he and
he stops howling
and he looks at his own
[ __ ]
is that you like that
he looks at his butt
as if to say who farted was that me i
feel terribly embarrassed and then he
looks back rounding
and that
is my favorite
20 seconds that's
hooked yeah yes yes it's my favorite 20
seconds that's happened on this planet
that we went to the first convention of
this year i believe was in william any
ideas first one was in calgary calgary
canada canada and billy sat me down at
lunchtime when he went you got to see
this and we watched it over and over
again and every single time we watched
it billy was in hysterics he didn't stop
as soon as he farted billy's laughing
then he goes back farts again laughing
how do did you ever do a re-enaction of
that oh
you should do when you're on your tick
tock you just do a due wet have it then
you just do it right next to it
what do you do on tick tock i i don't do
anything i just watched i just watched
you got to put a little you got to do it
i have never you got to add to the
community
the first one should be you
interacting or or or re-enacting what a
great idea dress is a hangout you don't
i mean you could you can go as far as
you want maybe it's just a hat or
something like that you know with the
big ears but that's a great idea i'll do
it
he's an exceptional farter as well and a
good actor
i could do both i'd like to see that
tick tock i could did you release your
tick tock or no your tick tock just a
private tick tock for nobody knows i
don't i'm not on tick tock i've never
been on tick tock and i'm nervous
because i'm a little obsessive
yeah
i really get into something and i know
if i get into tick tock i'm gonna what
do you put on yours well i do of course
i do some stuff for the fans that they
want to see from things from hook or
avatar but the one thing that i do that
became like a super viral thing because
i mean you know i'm not a kid i don't
know i can't do dances and stuff like
that i think like what would i want to
see like a tv show like a 20 second tv
show you know a minute long you can do a
three minute long video so the one of
the things i i did and just kind of has
been doing it is i do this thing called
residual check lottery
so you know we're actors i've been an
actor for 35 years now and so weekly i
get all these checks in the mail from
various things that come through
my my mailbox yeah and i'll take a stack
of them and i'll just take one out and
it's like residual check lottery you
guys remember
we're judging this check first of all
it's a check from something i've done
over the last 35 years that played
somewhere around the world
and uh
and i'm gonna judge this check by what
we can eat tonight it could be you know
it could be taco bell yeah yeah it could
be steak and lobster yeah and so yeah i
open the check and it's like you know
whatever and then it'll be like oh this
is from an episode i did of
the fresh prince of bel air and then
i'll show a little clip of it and i'll
come back and the whopping total is like
73 cents
taco bell night yeah taco bell night so
we i do a series of things like that
people love it and it's kind of fun to
kind of it's a good way for nostalgia
sometimes something good comes you know
i'll be like there's a few like it's
lobster time yeah yeah christmas time
good checks like i sent like gift gift
certificates to you know 10 fans you
know
have a meal on have a meal residual
check lottery i'll follow i don't even
follow anyone i followed that hound dog
and now i'm going to follow well i'm not
even there right now so when i can't
even follow you i can't william has not
been listening a guy in london diane
london you guys keep talking about
calgary in toronto stuff let me ask you
a question as you guys being brits or
you brett we're both great do you guys
find do you guys have a kinship to
canadians as they're part of the
commonwealth
well you see
nova scotia which is new scotland oh
i've been there i've been in nova scotia
i've been in nova scotia and that's new
scotland and i'm from old scotland so i
definitely have a kinship with those
okay what about the vancouver canucks
well that does yeah i love vancouver as
well i do i do feel like a lot of canada
does feel quite british still
um
yeah i do i do feel like you do you know
there's a whole french thing in the
middle there right right there's i mean
let's not maybe not so much
but i love that part as well yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah nova scotia in
particular they do like their cups of
tea and kind of
some british kind of
things in canada i like canada too i was
trying to think they're where around the
world do i feel like there's like a
natural affiliation with
and i'd recently spent some time in
ireland where i have extended
and without really thinking about it too
much but just instinctually in my bones
she's very boring there's like there was
a feeling on the street of like
these are my people this is where i'm
from monahan you know oh yeah monahan
you are so i just kind of and it's a
weird feeling that when you're in a
place that maybe because i've i hadn't
been to dublin apart from a couple of
like stag days and stuff but an extended
stain dublin remember walking around
week four or five and thinking i could
totally live here yeah people said i
mean i felt that me and my brothers went
to barcelona
and we were you know we're filipino and
so
manila we live in los angeles yeah and i
was like oh this all makes sense yeah
you know because also los angeles is
very spanish
yeah
it's derivative of that yeah and so the
philippines and we're like in barcelona
we're like hmm i i get it i get it i
went to manila i went and did an episode
of my nature show in the philippines
looking for the philippine flying lizard
ooh i've not seen the filipinos very
cool they're not very big a fully grown
adult is probably about this big which
if you're listening is about the size of
i would say a hot dog yeah yeah i wonder
where you're going to go with that yeah
and they don't they don't necessarily
fly they uh fall with grace terrible
name for them then yeah they should be
called the floating lizard or like the
flying squirrel they don't really fly
per
that's true there's only one flying
mammal anyone hey hold on
one flying mammal
lovely stuff
but manila i loved well is there a name
because i can't remember now and maybe
there isn't a name but you know those
very brightly ordained kind of taxi
bosses that picked up these jeepney
trucks
have you seen those mm-hmm
horns and lights
and they play crazy music i love yeah
jeep tricks are crazy this could be a
great time to say that we're going to
eat the world dom because i'll tell you
why
because it could be filipino
i think that's a great idea but could we
very s quickly squeeze in a league of
legends update oh i think we need to
yeah but i'm just worried about it
because i know he's got places to go but
like we got let's do league of legends
there's two things we need 20 minutes
two things we need what's he doing
because the other thing is you're going
to prep for a movie yeah are you
directing it well i directed my first
film it's called the fabulous filipino
brothers which is alan hulu right now
check it out on hulu
but i'm yeah i'm prepping to do a short
film that's another film we're shooting
in in europe uh later this year
what about sweden finland
yeah helsinki yeah falling in love in
broken english that's nowhere that's
right yes finland finland helsinki yeah
there's a famous monty python song
called finland you should check it out
michael palin's
the country where i most want to be pony
trekking or hiking
there you go just watching tv hey let's
do a league of legends updates
sorry about that
dante you play league of legends one of
the most exciting things i mean besides
hanging out with you guys i love that
you guys talk about league of legends
because i want to talk about league of
legends dude we're going to friend you
and play league of legends does everyone
know your name or is it secret yeah i
mean most people know
i'm rufiozuko
you're gonna get fired you're getting
friendly tonight let's go um well let's
talk about how long you've been playing
where do you play years years i was
first time i was going in one of my
producing partners brett claywell we
were going to pitch riot
the gaming company that that runs and
created league of legends and they said
they won't even see us until i was like
you know ranked like 30. you have to be
like at least level 30. and so i was
like what are you talking about and we
started playing the game and then i
hadn't i hadn't really played games
since high school really and then i got
really hooked on it and i got to level
30 and started you know playing now i
mean i'm a gamer i play different games
you know my twitch we play different
games but the one game that i do play
religiously like probably at least i
mean i wouldn't say every day but you
know several times a week yeah uh league
of legends i've known billy for 20 years
we've got into a whole bunch of stuff
together we have common interests we
have things that he does that i'm
interested in things that i do that he's
interested in i have never
shared certainly a gaming experience and
one of the more intense experiences with
billy that i have with league of legends
it's profound man and belief
you don't often in your life sit down
and say i'm gonna sit here for two hours
and do one well this is the thing right
i try to tell my friends and my brothers
and i can't get them all i've gotten a
few people in here i can't get them all
into it and they're like you know what
are you talking about the games i'm like
no no you understand it's
first of all you get to a certain age
where for us different for kids they're
pros at a very young age we still want
to be competitive at something and
you're not really playing certain sports
in the same way capacity right right
right but the reality they go what is it
i go it's
it's five on five basketball
meets dungeons and dragons
like what i'm like it's pickup
basketball it's like us going to the the
playground down the street and you got
your five friends or whatever and you're
playing pickup basketball with strangers
and you're going out and you're
competing on a level
but instead of being i mean and it's
just like it like you there's a point
guard there's like a
center there's a forward there's a
shooting guard everyone has a certain
talent you pick the kind of character
you want to play yeah you know tanky a
support person you want to do someone
would range who's doing an arrow you
want to be someone who's melee assassin
who goes in and just kills people and
every character has his strengths and
weaknesses
but we're playing like we're a team
we're a squad yeah we're a squad
and and i go you know it's a sport when
you're playing against someone who's
better than you and you can feel how
much better
just like on the basketball court like
yeah oh my god this guy's killing me
like i can't he's too fast
yeah it's the same thing you're like
i'm trying to get away and the guy's
he's too good yeah like okay then i
gotta get better yeah and i gotta get
some defenses i gotta get some i got you
start learning the things that you need
to learn for you to be better on that
playing field also how about the fact
that
no game is like the next no we you play
on the same man right same lane yeah
kind of doing the same character same
stuff and you think oh ice is going to
be you know but it's saying everything's
totally different
who got who into it he got me into it
and he didn't think i would stick with
it and i don't think i would say i
haven't really played a game since atari
that's uh this is how i was until i got
to league of legends yeah and for some
reason it because it's
it's super difficult for like
10 minutes right or like the learning
curve learning
but once you get what you can do once
you can get where you can actually play
a game right then you're good now you're
starting to understand what's going on
because you can understand when you're
winning and losing yeah and you
understand why they're winning yeah
just all the little things like this
there's the towers there so you can use
the tower right so when you're not great
you can kind of hang by the tower
you know what i mean no of course not
like you're stuck there's things that
you can do for yourself yeah now we're
totally we're getting super smart
so you could do things like a basketball
player i can get my shot better i can
get my drive better however the other
aspect of the game is it's a team sport
so now it's
usually
you know every now and then one good
player can win the whole thing but very
rare because you need
you're playing five people yeah yeah and
so there's become strategy you're
listening to each other you gotta you're
you're relying on each other like i
can't just win this alone i need you to
come and gank me yeah yeah to to get a
strategy here we can't fall behind like
you if i'm you know if i'm picking can
you pick up the slack if i'm not doing
well or you see your your partner not
doing what's like it's not good to yell
at them go help them out right it's like
yeah
it's a trick it's a trick teaming so
there's a little you know you improve
your play but you also have to like
strategize with you know real people not
computer people and the people you're
playing are not bots they're they're
real people censoring their hands in and
of itself is pretty amazing and what who
who's your favorite character just now
and where's your favorite i mean i'm an
abc on which is bot lane and uh you know
jinx and ash are my my main lovely stuff
my main plays but i have a character for
each lane because you never know sure
who you're gonna have to play with so
give us give us one
time
i'm going garen tops
classic and or quinn but garen usually
i'm uh i'm gonna go mid ahri which is
also a min
and then if i gotta go
jungle which i'm probably not the
greatest because i don't really
understand the dynamics of how i'm
always behind in gold if i do i don't
like i don't know where i'm going yeah
yeah yeah
it's really difficult right i'll do i
mean i'll do a shyvana dragon sometimes
or uh what's my guy with what throws the
things the little and a little yordle
guy that walks around
not teemo i hate him
but the yeah what's his i give his name
slipping my tongue right what does he
throw he throws like the the strings and
he grabs you and he goes in jungle guy
needs cries
i'll do a muumuu a jungle because that
if i do a mummy junk i feel like a
support jungler
don't expect too much from me have you
seen that cinematic on a moomoo that
riot made no no oh you should check it
out so the i went to the dentist a few
weeks ago and obviously there's a tv on
the ceiling and the dentist said what do
you want to watch we can watch something
on netflix or youtube and i said i'll go
on youtube and i thought i'll watch a
little league of legends thing but you
know they're only like 10 15 minutes
long so i thought i'm gonna be in here
for an hour i'm gonna have to keep
changing it someone has put together
every single riot cinematic in order in
chronological wow it's like two hours
like makes sense
it's like two hours long the standout
ones are the annie video the way that
annie came to be which is beautiful
but the moomin one comes with a really
beautiful song and it's basically just
him crying in ancient egypt and how he
got to the map it's really beautiful oh
great great give me your support before
we finish this oh my oh my sports sona
sona supports
lovely stuff well um
billy unfortunately is a little
in a good way a little stuck on
heimerdinger because he's brilliant
i mean i'm kind of a one-trick pony too
more or less but yeah you have to pick
one character who would have thought
over a million points
yeah jinx is amazing but also i mean
what's cool looks like i've been playing
for so long like one of my characters
american dragon jake long jinx's
firecracker skin is jake long the
american dragon oh that's wicked yeah so
like i play my my little i love
universal alts it's one of my favorite
things which is why i play jinx as well
because i was like you can be way right
away from a sniper are you a sniper are
you a sniper and you can be like oh let
me just send something in to see if
that's why i love ash too because
i mean yeah you know supposedly ash is
based on one of the riot owners wives
wow i'm not sure if she's called ash but
certainly the influence for that person
he said to his wife if you're a player
in this if you were a character in this
game who would you be
she created it with him and that's like
a tribute to his wife because she's a
classic she's like one of the og
characters she's amazing a bit too slow
for me but i love her i know but you
when she scales up oh yeah she's a beast
she's devastating she's devastating well
we can talk all day but we should
probably eat the world yes come on let's
see
billy and dom eat the world
johnny's coming in with stuff
uh yeah so obviously every week we like
to
either introduce our guest to something
that billy and i are into or
have our guest
bring something in and you've brought
something for us right dante yes there's
a
there's a specialty from my
my homeland i might have had this when i
was in the philippines you know okay so
dante yes what have you brought for us
so i have a little uh just you know i
don't know it's a delicacy it's common
food for my area of the world the
philippines and it's the lumpia and
something i grew up with my mom made
lumpy as my grandmother made lumpias and
it's essentially i guess people think of
it like an egg roll but you know as a
filipino like it's not an egg roll it's
essentially egg it's a filipino egg roll
it's called olympia it's uh for people
out there listening it's really you know
like a a piece of i don't know if it's
like a tortilla but it's like a wrap we
call the olympia wrapper wrapped with
meats inside or vegetables johnny here's
um
what maybe you're maybe you're a perfect
guest to ask wha what is the difference
between an egg roll and a spring roll or
are these this i don't know i think
that's more from china so i'd have to
ask that but i think it's the same thing
too but i do think
and again i may be wrong
thanks johnny egg rolls fried spring
roll maybe
not fried okay you know i could tell you
something about the rapper there william
please i could tell you about the rapper
if you like please please talk to me
about the wrap um because it says each
lumpia
consists of a flower or rice wrapper
rice wrapper stuffed with assorted meat
and vegetables and sealed with egg wash
commonly the final step is then to deep
fry it however they may also be served
fresh it's a widespread dish yeah
several variations can we try it come
here
this is like we call this shanghai style
william if you could be my favorite
pasta
we have this phrase shall i be mother
which means shall i shall i help how am
i doing
john do you know what the filling is in
this would it be beef would it be pork
would it
just are they are they all the same
we don't know what it is i'll take two
take two
dip it i'll do a little dippy william
i'm sorry i've got one of my fingers
there and then there's uh there's
there's a vegetable one too but these
are meat ones i don't tend to eat pork
but i'll make an exception yeah i mean
the thing about pork in the filipinos is
it's a it's a common thing my girlfriend
doesn't eat pork so that was a little
treat for me too
and um um
[Music]
now would this be
would it be fair to say that this is a
street food street food street food
appetizer and there's different sizes
these small shanghai once they smell and
chop up there's bigger thicker ones that
are like
mostly vegetables there's a dessert one
that's a banana or a plantain in it and
it's called a toronto so there's like a
you know it's kind of like most cultures
it's like a little
it's like a filipino little meat burrito
small one
it's really delicious
and did you see that all your family
kind of makes this yeah my mom made it
my mom had olympia company growing up in
our home yeah there's a picture of me in
our hometown pittsburg california in the
newspaper me he like eating lumpia
because my mom was like you know they
did a story on her making columbia
said lombia is typically served by the
dozen and can either be an appetizer or
an entree sweet and sour sauce which
we've got is also the most popular
choice of sauce to complement a dish
well the savory options are more common
they're also dessert versions of the
dish right most of the dessert
versions
use a banana filling with different
options to top the crunchy outer shell
some include sorry about this billy
cinnamon sugar sorry about that
chocolate drizzle caramel and even ice
cream or bananas
banana yes that sounds great it's my
favorite growing up for sure look quite
nice aren't they william yeah i've got a
lot of got did your mom's business um
just uh was it just out of the house
kind of thing kind of out of the house
yeah this is in the 80s and the great
thing about when you get homemade
olympia the rappers are homemade so my
memories of my mom making the rice
wrapper by hand she had like one of
those skillets and the thing and she
would like kind of put it on there and
make these fresh lumpy we used to eat
the wrappers like raw just
like the house smells amazing and then
it's the whole thing the whole family
getting together putting the meat or the
vegetables in it wrapping it up and then
you kind of store them up and then you
what happens is you you fry them fresh
so like when they order them where
people come they usually would get it
raw or frozen from my mom's thing and
then they go home and they fry them and
serve them uh so they're nice and so
nice
billy i don't think either one of us
would do very well with this task but uh
could i ask you to read the second
paragraph underlying me i think i would
do terrible at the second part let's see
let's see
on you go mills although olympia
technically originates from fujihan
china
it was brought to southeast asia by
chinese traders as early as the 7th to
the 13th century
in the days of the srivisian
empire there you go and later the yes
in the 13th to the 16th century and
that's according to
chinesefoodhistory.org
thank you you did it better than i would
i love that i'm going to have one more
of these things too like all right
if you
[Music]
someone was saying the other day and i
think i heard this on a podcast but
someone was saying
i think it was a musician and they were
saying you know how do you attribute
your success where did that come from
and all this kind of stuff and they had
said i'm also a long-distance runner and
they said as a long-distance runner one
of the major things that you need to do
is just get to the starting line get
your [ __ ] get the right shoes on get
your shorts on do your training get to
the starting line that's half the right
and he
can't remember who this was but he
attributed the fact that then as a
musician
his guitar is in good nick right he gets
to stage on time he does sound check he
does the show and i think a lot of times
as actors half the battle is like
knowing your lines hitting your marks
having the right attitude the rest of it
is if they like you or not yeah i mean
you know hopefully you do some training
on the waist once you get that's when
they say throw it out once you gotta
throw it out once they're paying you to
do the gig
there's no more time to doubt you hope
that every you hope you've done enough
preparation
for it to fly and how does that transfer
to directing a movie know that you've
directed i mean it's fascinating because
like i said i've been in the industry
over 35 years and i directed my first
film just before coven it came out right
and the fabulous filipino brothers and
what happened was
i've been producing for years and it's
been really interesting spreading your
wings from acting to writing to
directing and i wrote the script
but then it happens where you
you don't know how much you know until
you actually have to apply it
you know what i'm saying and so it's
like i'm on the set and when i'm doing
my team and just like uh even as a
producer it just got to a point where
like
i became the most senior person on the
set and you're working all these young
filmmakers out of films or whatnot and
they're asking
this happened and like what happened
you're going ah well this one time on
the set
something like this happened then we did
this and then just little by little you
start to understand what you actually
know and then of course when you're
talking about directing you're talking
about filmmaking you're talking all the
movies that you've watched all the the
directors you've worked with all the
other actors you've worked with and it
just becomes not a place of egos it's a
place of like
what's gonna serve this film like
and so
i'm an actor's actor i'm an actress
director i love actors i love
storytelling i love dps and i love the
whole crew when we do that but i'm i'm
still an actor that wants to tell the
story and wants these
i want the actor to win in front of when
we're active i want the actor to win so
i'm trying to like just you know kind of
ease him in the right place to kind of
do the thing but it's so exciting
because
when you get it right you know the air
in the room changes it's like theaters
like you guys when they hit you know
you've done a performance so many times
but when it that that's that moment
happens it's like the air in the room
changes when we hit that chord correctly
and and it and it really resonated at
the same time when we were on the set
when i when my brothers and the actors
would do this scene in a certain way i
was like did we get them like
check the focus because it was there i i
felt it i didn't have to watch it i'm
there i'm in this i'm in the scene with
these guys so yeah it's just
i think it's just you know just a next
chapter and an evolution for all of us
as artists you know very cool man yeah
imagine how many great artists are in
the room just now but feel like they can
go out and do it because
so many people like you're talking about
that running a marathon
think well i can't run a marathon and
and they won't think about
running for five minutes until they can
think of themselves running a marathon
it's the same as making a movie right
they well i can't make a movie because i
don't yeah they think about a finnish
movie whereas you have to think of it as
moments and just moment upon moment and
as you said it's in focus
it's there now we can use that moment to
help taylor and then you as a young man
14 speaking to spielberg and talking
about the movies that you loved it's
all connected yeah it's so connected
and it's lovely here let's just say my
girlfriend's from china she always gives
me chinese proverbs and she's like how
do you eat an elephant i go what she
goes one bite at a time yeah
that's all it is one bite at a time so
remember anyone any maybe young people
out there who want to make a movie or
they want to be an actor you don't have
to
be perfect for that first time you try
it right you keep doing it you keep
doing it and before you know it you make
something beautiful practice
my favorite chinese proverb is confucius
man who cooks carrots and peas in the
same pot is unhygienic
we'll move on um we're going to give
their scores we give these scores dante
so we've got we do three categories all
right the first one being flavor and or
taste all right
flavor i mean how do you mess with that
so attempt and you can give up decimal
points i'm going to start
it's a deep fried meaty treat and i
think if it was fresh if it was fresh
it's going to be better yeah my better i
mean i'd have to give that
an
i like it i like i'll take it because
that's a good flavor yeah look at it
super tasty it would jump up if it was
freshly fried yeah
exactly freshly fried but 8.9 is all i
can do okay
i've not eaten pork for a long time and
it was lovely and this and the sweet and
sour sauce was fantastic i'm gonna drop
it down a little bit
because pork isn't necessarily my thing
i'm gonna give it
a 7.6 i liked it
listen my my girlfriend doesn't eat pork
and my mom changed her recipe for my
girlfriend so now we're having a turkey
oh that's great
minced turkey in there do you want to
give it a score
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
yeah i'll leave it to you too
i have too much history
across the board it's a ten for my
mother this is not my mother's yeah it's
a time for my mother's always okay next
thing is aesthetics how does it look
okay
how does it look how does it when you
look at it are you charmed and it looks
a little bit like a cigar would that be
like a miniature cigar or a cigarillo
like a self-rolled cigar like a tiny cup
cannoli without the stuff inside it
uh it's nice but i mean it's not
changing the world we did exactly what
you did growing up our whole lives right
we smoked them we always smoked
something
from the a-team we pretended smoke you
have b.a did you smoke it hannibal
hannibal smith smith yeah did you ever
do it like uh de niro yes oh yeah i
could see you as a young actor being a
deniro smoker of these things do you
know i still know the start of the a
team we should do that wait till you
hear this go
in 1972 a crack command unit was sent to
prison by a military court for a crime
they didn't commit these men probably
escaped from a maximum security stockade
until los angeles underground today
still wanted by the government they
survive as soldiers of fortune if you
can hire them no if you need help then
you can hire them and you can find them
no way
if you're in trouble and you need help
and you can find them maybe you could
hire
no i think i'm more i think you're more
faced you're you'll do murder i think
i'm more murdered murdoch howling mad
murdoch
there's one more we need a hannibal
smith we need a leader
maybe it's johnny maybe it's johnny
johnny johnny clues is hannibal smith
right in terms of the aesthetics bills
i'm going to drop it down a little bit
because it it's fine but it's not
changing the world it's not changing the
words it's it's more of an appetizer
kind of thing it's a 6.5 for me i still
like the look of it i'm giving an 8.2
there you go oh [ __ ] there you go now
this is where i think it comes into its
own billy's favorite category
how useful is it
there's a movie that just came out my
brother's in it's called olympia 2 the
revenge of
there's a olympia superhero oh wow what
was his power
his power's lumpia
as a weapon wow just want to throw that
out there to you right now like little
cali sticks little boom i don't know if
there's magic in there uh he's just he
he he he throttles people with olympia
sometimes well mine's like going through
someone no no just kind of like diverts
them my thing is and this isn't always
accurate but in my head it's can you
take it to a soccer game and give it out
to either the people watching the game
or the team at half time and i think you
could do that with you you can of course
this was nice of course it's a football
game
yeah when i brought up this uh how how
useful is it that wasn't really what i
was meaning
i was meaning like could you like put it
in to like a food processor and make it
into powder other stuff and then put it
on a cake or
you know if you if you went into your
room
malleable
and you've got three eggs oh yeah you've
got mayonnaise
you've got some bread
ice cream
three bananas
two plums
in olympia who's done the shopping that
week that's weird she's terrible
olympia and then what could you do could
it help you create a meal can you do a
lumpy a pie could you do it
no no no lumpy is a great leftover in
and of itself no thought if it's in the
refrigerator you got something to eat
heat up how do you heat or cold
would you heat it up
i mean i would i wouldn't microwave
because it gets soggy i would throw it i
would throw it over the the toaster oven
boom is it is it popular at weddings and
or funerals
every
almost any filipino
event that you will go to will have
olympia well that's quite useful bills
it's quite versatile yeah it's widely
expected it's it's widely accepted at
any event that's expected expected and
expected and accepted like american
express i'm gonna get i'm gonna give it
a 9.2 my goodness usefulness there you
go as if i i like what it is but i don't
think it's that useful did you just
click your fingers no okay i went with
that right as dante hit his butt
okay sound effects fault folly
six point eight
it's all oh it's all right we like it we
have to say that we'll like it yeah it's
fantastic thanks for bringing it i i i i
appreciate it i'm going to have one more
just go for it just make sure no i don't
know if billy's told you but he's
bulking
he's trying to need those calories
and also i think if you were to go down
the line of big bulky strong men
brilliant
but could you also flirt with the idea
of just big whopping version of billy
boyd the biggest version of billy mm-hmm
of course there'll be muscles in there
but i'd like to see you get massive like
first ones like orson welles like like
marlon brando when he was getting later
something like that right maybe what i
think about it i want these trousers to
be useless yeah they've split you'll
come into the podcast
skin all your clothes skins
well dante's been amazing thank you guys
so much it's a pleasure you have to head
to uh joshua treatment
getting tested right now for the
preparations
we're making movies and i'll see you
guys in toronto and i'll see you guys on
the rift we'll see you on the rift see
you on the rift and everyone can see us
all in toronto at fan expo on the
weekend of august the 27th
cheers
[Music]
you're shining bright i'm your boy's the
baby you're my pearl